we're joined by the human rights lawyer
mark guthrie for his take on the
terrible scenes we saw unfold here on
sky news yesterday mr guthrie perhaps
you can talk to me about what james
heapey was saying there he was convinced
that what we witnessed unfold at that
maternity hospital in maripole
was a war crime he then went on to talk
about evidence
what's your take on what we saw unfold
well the minister is broadly right i
mean he's he set it out in very uh
clear terms i suppose as a lawyer i
would say is that
what the war cri which war crimes
anybody would be charged with
is going to depend on on the evidence
but broadly speaking he's right and he's
right to say that liability for war
crimes
runs from top to bottom
it's um
probably more it certainly is more
difficult to prosecute those at the top
than those at the bottom but
those who wage war are accountable under
the law
let's go back to the beginning what are
war crimes from what we've seen over the
last two weeks can you give us some
examples
of what western countries you know
overwhelmingly a number of western
countries have gone to the international
criminal court and said we are
witnessing war crimes what specifically
are they talking about
okay there are three broad categories of
war-related crimes at the very top
you've got genocide and president
zielinski described
what happened to the children's hospital
in mario paul yesterday
as genocide that's going to depend on
the evidence because to prove genocide
you've got to prove that there is a
concerted effort
to wipe out a a national group
then you've got crimes against humanity
um and that's a systematic
attack
a systematic for example murder of
of people
um and that those who perpetrate crimes
against humanity have got to know about
that attack
and then you've got
grave breaches of the geneva convention
of 1949
uh
breaches of international humanitarian
law
and those would be
attacks on civilians attacks on civilian
objects so the attack on the hospital
there's a strong strong case to answer
um that that is um a
a war crime a breach
of the uh geneva conventions which
protect um civilians
um in the time of war talk to me about
how evidence is gathered we're looking
at a video here of what happened at that
hospital in maripo um but what would the
international criminal court for example
be looking at how is a case put together
well
um as the uh prosecutor at the icc is
seeing to doing he's sending a team of
investigators so you're looking at me
you're looking at
obviously what's happened on the ground
you've been looking at video evidence
and then ultimately you'll also be
relying upon the the ev the evidence of
military analysts such as the air com
commodore you had on previously looking
at analyzing all that and that's
particularly important for offences such
as genocide
and and crimes against uh humanity
because you're looking at
murder on a widespread scale as part of
an overall plan
probably um
grave breaches
of the geneva convention
are war crimes which are most
straightforward um to prove
um
but it's
it's a case of putting the pieces
together
as as in any other cry isn't any a crime
it's gathering all the pieces of
evidence together
um you mentioned before that those who
can be liable
for war crimes go from the bottom to the
top so we're talking about foot soldiers
general all the way up to vladimir putin
himself and i was wondering if you could
explain something to me that has been
talked about this week the labour leader
sikhistan has brought it up the mp tom
tuggenheart and the foreign secretary
liz trust talked about it and this is
the crime of aggression
under which political leaders and
military chiefs can be held individually
responsible for an invasion that is
being talked about as being leveled of
vladimir putin but there is a difficulty
in holding him to account for that can
you explain it to us
well they're they're looking they're
looking at the nature of the aggression
which
nature of the war which russia has
unleashed against ukraine but even if
you were trying um vladimir putin
for crimes at the international criminal
court for for war crimes you're going to
have
there is a problem
in that of course he's in russia
and he's not going to voluntarily
surrender
so getting him
to stand trial
is going to be very very difficult and
you you and your viewers remember
that you know the war crimes
prosecutions in bosnia herzegovina and
how long it took
to get uh radhavan kharagic the leader
of the republic of sarpska in bosnia
herzegovina and the leader of the
bosnian serbs to get him to stand trial
obviously he went underground
so
it's not going to be easy to put anybody
at the top level
on trial maybe easier at the bottom
level but the other thing to remember is
that this is not going to happen
soon it's going to be you know
if any there is any prosecution
uh unfortunately it's going to be a long
time in the future
mark guthrie human rights lawyer we
really appreciate you uh talking us
through all of that thank you for your
time this afternoon here on sky news
thank you